the man in black fled across the desert
and the gunslinger followed
jack torrance thought a vicious little
prick almost everyone thought the man
and the boy were father and son
once upon a time not so long ago a
monster came to the small town of castle
rock maine
the terror which would not end for
another 28 years
if it ever did end began so far as i
know or can tell
with a boat made from a sheet of
newspaper floating down a gutter swollen
with rain
hello stephen king is quickly becoming
one of my favorite writers
how does he get you in those opening
pages and those opening lines sometimes
today i'm trying to figure out what
makes stephen king's beginnings
so effective and i think there's a few
things
but before i get into it i would like to
preface this by saying
this is just my opinion there are three
things i find
that make stephen king's openings so
successful
first is something is
wrong something is off something is
unusual
the second thing is establishing
personality whether he's writing the
first person or third person
whether he's writing as stephen king or
trying to get into the head of his
narrator there is a feeling that we are
inside the mind and experiencing the
thoughts of someone who has
a distinct personality who's not just a
robot and the third thing is
establishing point of view as fast as
possible there is an
urgency to understand the characters and
the characters are
put first so let's look at misery
number one
these sounds even in the haze okay
so that's one that's like the first
section one and then two
all right first off we get the sense
that something something is off because
it's it's a bit unusual to start that
way
um however i think there is a strong
indicator of personality
in just in that brief little segment
that's just
noise basically it presents a mystery
okay first mystery of the book what the
[ __ ] is that noise
i don't know i guess i better keep
reading and then it's so vague
these sounds even in the haze there's a
haze
there is some perspective right we're in
somebody's head
and it's very easy to just jump onto the
next thing first off
i i really like how stephen king will
will do this with his chapters he'll
divide them
and number them too i know a lot of
writers do that but it seems like
something stephen king does a lot and it
really helps
keep the pace flowing but sometimes the
sounds like the pain
faded and then there was only the haze
he remembered darkness
solid darkness had come before the haze
did that mean he was making progress
let there be light even of the hazy
variety and the light was good
and so on and so on had those sounds
existed in the darkness
he didn't know the answers to any of
these questions did it make sense to ask
them
he didn't know the answer to that one
either i think we already get a sense
that there's some humor in this
character in this personality
we're with somebody it's it's kind of
casual
and personal and we feel a personality
on the other side of the page
the pain was somewhere below the sounds
the pain was east of the sun
and south of his ears that was all he
did know
and i think uh stephen king does this
with a lot of his books
he will kind of throw a reader in to a
situation
but what he never like keeps
or hides away is a character gives us
this person to latch on to
in the writing itself which it can be
casual which can be
and these are just basic i think i think
these are basic rules for
for starting a good book and i think any
writer you know if you're you're
interested in writing
that stephen king is a great resource to
figure out how to hook your
your audience instantly so
anyways that's my little that's my very
brief those are my brief thoughts about
stephen king's
openings about stephen king's beginnings
yeah we did it have a good one